[Music]
today a federal court ruled that you
cannot ban
same-sex marriage in california
that's the ruling yeah
in other words
in other words my weekend with andy just
got a lot more interesting
[Applause]
that's it i proposed to you on the air
and nothing
i'm already married yeah people still
talk about the super bowl halftime show
yesterday the tightrope walker remember
him remember him
it was 48 hours ago the tightrope walker
from madonna's halftime show said my
nuts are fine
yeah
what's strange is that he said that in
response to the question what's it like
to work with madonna
[Applause]
[Music]
anyone here go to jack-in-the-box every
you like jack-in-the-box
wow
that was very enthusiastic
they said like they think you're gonna
take them right now
everyone get in the back of my dad's
station wagon
i'm going to jack-in-the-box
you don't want to go in that car
it's a 1978
it's
oldsmobile
piece of crap uh
no fast food chain jack-in-the-box has
introduced a bacon milkshake
yeah this is all part of
jack-in-the-box's new die happy meal
[Applause]
your heart explodes
it's like the alien an alien
this is a crazy story out of iran iran
is banning toys that are based on the
simpsons
iran banning toys and simpsons yeah when
asked why president ahmadinejad said
iran is more of a family guy country
the obama administration this is
controversial the obama administration
is being slammed for a new health
insurance rule that forces catholic
organizations to provide contraception
forces them yeah even more controversial
the church would also have to provide
dim lighting wine coolers and an r kelly
mixtape
you started to laugh halfway through and
you didn't hear the very end
when i said r kelly mixtape which
was my favorite part you see
that
thank you
[Music]
how dare you laugh too early
it ruined everything
still not going to marry me
uh i told you i'm married to a lady i've
already yeah it's i i hate to break your
heart in front of everyone but all right
we'll see you
you know you're married to a lady for a
team she doesn't care
whatever you want just get out of here
[Laughter]
this is crazy in michigan a senate
candidate is being accused of racism for
a new campaign ad where a chinese woman
speaks in comically broken english
people are mad
yeah today the candidate issued an
apology saying me love china long time
right now
crazy listen to this scientists have
created a bullet check this out a bullet
that is capable of guiding itself to the
target
yeah unfortunately before the bullet can
find the right direction it has to spend
at least a year backpacking around
europe
we argued about that one backstage
[Applause]
i said
and i said we can do it
and we did it
and now i regret it
any marvel comic book fans here
i forgot it's nerdfest
[Applause]
i'm sorry it's a legitimate enthusiasm
who am i to mock them
see i grew up a jock really so it's hard
for me to
i'll be quiet marvel comics is updating
the fantastic four to give the heroes
things like smartphones and ipads
yeah
yeah so now when the hulk gets mad he
rips his shirt and shouts hulk send
angry text
hulk no lol
okay tiny buttons yeah